hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
today we're gonna go back into
neuroscience we're very very happy to
have Patricia Churchland on the show
Patricia Churchland is an extremely
celebrated and influential
neuroscientist and philosopher in fact
one of her claims to fame is
popularizing the phrase neuro philosophy
so as you might guess she's a
philosopher of mind but someone who
thinks we're going to learn about the
mind by studying the brain and tries to
make connections between what happens to
us as people
our conscious selves and what's going on
in the brain the neurons their
connections their firings and so forth
in fact I think that Patricia is the
first MacArthur Fellow to appear here on
mindscape you know the MacArthur
fellowships the genius grants so
everyone we have as a guest is a genius
in one way or another but she's
officially a genius and her most recent
book is going to be the topic we're
talking about today which is conscience
not conscious or consciousness
conscience as in Jiminy Cricket right as
in the part of our inner cells that says
you know you really shouldn't be doing
that
or you really should be doing this thing
that you're not doing obviously this
there's a relationship here between this
idea of conscience and other ideas we
talked about on the podcast the parts of
our thinking and the parts of our
selfhood that come from our brains and
our bodies right not simply higher
cognition rationality and so forth but
the impulses that we have that make us
who we are and so Patricia Churchland
has thought about these things more
carefully than anybody we're going to
talk about not only what conscience is
how it relates to emotions and
intuitions and instincts but also how it
relates to specific things going on in
the brain we'll talk about oxytocin you
know the cuddle molecule and we'll talk
about where this leads us in terms of
morality and empathy right you know
there's gonna be a vs. ought kind of
discussion in there we will not
completely resolve it but I think we're
basically on the same side one way or
another it's always a delight to talk to
Patricia Churchland by the way her
husband Paul Churchland is also a famous
neuroscientist and philosopher and they
have two children both of whom became
neuroscientists
so maybe there's some genetic
determinism going on there I'm not sure
anyway this is a wonderful discussion
but rich is always good to talk to not
only because she has a charming Canadian
accent but she's also one of the
smartest people I know so let's go
[Music]
Kirkland welcome the mindscape podcast
lovely to be here so I know that there's
no academic in the world who would be
happy to have their entire career
reduced to a single word but I have to
say that you have a word that is very
associated with you namely neuro
philosophy maybe you can tell us a
little bit about what that is and how it
came to be well I think of neuro
philosophy in the following way that it
it kind of works the ground that exists
between neuroscience on the one hand and
the grand old philosophical questions on
the other hand so and I sort of came of
age so to speak at the time when
neuroscience was developing to the
degree that you could begin to see that
it was going to have an impact on all of
the big questions how do we make
decisions and choose what's the nature
of learning and memory how do we know
anything what's the nature of
consciousness ancient questions here
yeah ancient questions and I think one
of the things that really motivated me
were the split brain results because
here you had these subjects who because
they had epilepsy that couldn't be
treated with drugs underwent surgery in
where the surgery consisted in
separating the two hemispheres the idea
was that you didn't want the epileptic
seizure to travel from one hemisphere to
the other and at first of course people
thought no didn't really make any
difference to anything except the
epilepsy isn't that grand but then it
turned out that if you looked very
closely the hemispheres sort of speak
new different things were aware of
different things and it's not like you
had two people exactly but it the fact
that one hemisphere could be consciously
aware of something while the other one
was not was really profound because it
meant that all these years we had these
abstract arguments about you know is
there a mind that's separate from the
brain and if there is
were and I thought this just makes it
flaming obvious if consciousness can be
split by cutting a set of nerve fibers
game over now I don't want to do these
arguments anymore that are in the
abstract what I want to do is understand
the thing itself and when you proposed
this idea of neuro philosophy was that
immediately well accepted throughout the
various community oh yes well it took a
while to come to fruition at the time
Paul and I were on the faculty at the
University of Manitoba
in the philosophy department that
Poulter thing Paul Churchill knew is my
husband that's right
and because things were not run as a
really tight ship and they we had a
certain amount of flexibility I decided
that if I was going to really think
about the brain in obscure in a
thoroughgoing way I had to really
understand Anatomy and you can't
understand Anatomy by looking at a
two-dimensional picture because the
brains the three-dimensional thing so I
went down to the medical school and
explained my dilemma to the head of the
anatomy department and he said oh this
is wonderful he was an Englishman John
Baskerville hide and baskerville hide
said oh this is this is great you should
come and do all of the neuroscience you
want come to the neuroanatomy classes
you should go to neurology rounds and
see patients and so forth and so as soon
as I'd taught my classes I get my old
beat-up jalopy and I roar down to the
medical school and it was bliss I could
it was just the most sort of eye-opening
wondrous experience for me to really
begin to understand what we didn't
didn't know what we could know if we had
new tools and so forth and but the
philosophy the Philosopher's rebelled a
little bit at this idea that there
should even be a thing
neuro philosophy so when I find me wrote
the book and the book came out yes there
there was consternation by and large the
philosophers hated it and still do they
think that I mean it the interesting
thing to me was that even philosophers
who didn't think there was spooky stuff
who didn't think there was a mind
independent was the brain yeah they said
the brain is actually irrelevant and I
mean Dan Dennett was a great case in
point cuz he now presents himself as
being very brain friendly but let me
tell you in those days he was entirely
great hostile he would say look there's
a difference between the software and
the hardware I don't need to understand
a computer in order to understand how to
work say Microsoft Word so since
cognition is running software on the
hardware I don't need to know about
neurons I mean that actually makes sense
that argument I know I mean it's not
true it's not correct but at that level
of analysis it's plausible it was except
it really wasn't because even at that
time we knew very well that the brain
was not like a digital computer yeah
that the very connections between
neurons changed as you learn something
there wasn't the memory box there wasn't
you know RAM and we knew that the
processing was all parallel it wasn't
like it is in a digital computer and we
also knew that very tiny changes at the
microstructure could affect the nature
of cognition and like you say in
retrospect it makes sense because
hardware versus software is a very human
construct right and he did not appoint
the brain did not evolve yeah
and in fact there was a wonderful
occasion to put Francis Crick and I and
Dan Dennett we're having dinner and
Francis knew about this this
software/hardware story of dads and so
he started to push him and
inimitable way that Francis had about
you know you don't care about neurons
and don't you understand how you can't
get function except out of structure and
if you don't understand the structure
you're not gonna understand the function
so that was that was rather interesting
but most most philosophers had a lot of
sympathy with Dan's take on things there
were others loss of hers who thought
that really the job of philosophers is
to lay down the foundations for science
and so why would we look to science to
do those foundations we the
Philosopher's are going to tell you what
you can discover and what you can't
discover is how we think by looking at
the brain that was their basic story and
also if we're gonna get into morality
and consciousness and things like that
and I presume that hopefully you can
fill in but I presume that some of the
philosophers thought that what is right
and what is wrong should be independent
of what's going on in the brains like
maybe it will help us think about how we
get there but what the answers are
should be true for computers and lizards
and human beings equally yeah yeah I
kind of think so
and I think something like that was
especially true about the nature of
morality so there there had been this
long-standing project by long-standing I
guess I mean in the 20th century where
really the project was for philosophers
to uncover this very special thing this
rule that is the absolute rule that
applies to all people under all
conditions at all times and that's what
they would try to dream up and they'd
argue about it and they'd go back and
forth and it was alright you know was
all erased a time well well I don't know
there was a waste of time but it was but
I think that you you wouldn't want to
say oh we should get into it's much
older than 20th century right I mean
cond Descartes
Aristotle probably in Plato talked about
what are the
general rules for morality no
interestingly I mean this is this is
something I find really fascinating is
that actually just like there are sort
of two traditions about the mind
there's the physicalist tradition and
then there is the the dualist tradition
so in morality there are the it's all
about rules and there are the people who
say no look rules are at best sort of
soft guidelines and they don't apply to
all situations so if you're going to
have people behave in a moral way there
has to be something that is deeper than
that and what those are are the values
that people pick up and why would they
do that
and here Ariston hugh charles darwin all
agreed it has to be something that is
part of our nature hmm well as opposed
to pure reason as opposed to pure reason
whereas corporal Condit was all about
pure reason and and and this demarcated
in ancient Greece a profound difference
between Aristotle in one hand and Plato
Plato who thought that the absolute
truths were in this abstract third realm
that could be accessed through as he
said intellection Aristotle was a man of
the world a necessity and then peer
assist and he he didn't think that that
made any sense every thought was an
obvious mistake on my part
adding him how I shouldn't say you know
but Plato and Kant yes they did that
this idea it's also so I wondered
something that actually was spurred by
reading a couple of your books I'm gonna
float a crazy hypothesis and w-what you
think yeah because you mentioned along
with Aristotle and Hume as people who
are more on the side of there's not one
simple rule there's a bunch of
indications or guidelines and let's work
through it you also mention Eastern
traditions and Sood ISM Confucianism and
Native American traditions both wisdom
et cetera I wonder if the Western
philosophical tradition of looking
the one true rule has anything to do
with monotheism even among philosophers
who are not necessarily religious
there's sort of the spirit that will get
the one right answer which is maybe less
congenial if you're a Confucian ister
Buddhist I think it is sort of appealing
it certainly didn't appeal to Hume and
and that Adam Smith but then they were
both kind of atheists yeah
but perhaps something like the ten
commandments is in the back of people's
minds certainly in the back of the mind
of Aquinas and and almost certainly cond
who was a Christian but didn't think
that it was God who actually provided
the rules he just provided us with the
reason to figure them out yeah I think
that's not not surprising I think that's
a very interesting hypothesis well you
tell the wonderful story about asking
what the Buddhist version of the Ten
Commandments would be well yes I mean
this was an amazing occasion that was
arranged by one of the people who
started the department of neuroscience
here at UCSD who's now gone Bob
Livingston and the Dalai Lama wanted to
know about the brain and so Bob
collected a few of us took us up to Los
Angeles where the Dalai Lama was staying
and we had these meetings with him and
at lunchtime I it was able to be a
decent I had a Buddhist priest next to
me and so I began the conversation and I
sort of said and all my ignorance so so
what in Buddhism corresponds to the 10
commandments and of course now I realize
how embarrassing that was and how how
graciously he didn't look embarrassed
for me but that it was amazing because
then he went on to talk about the very
different style of thinking through
moral issues that prevails in Buddhism
and and when the Dalai Lama then gave
his public lecture he actually worked
the same themes and it really had a big
effect on me because I thought I am I
had not been particularly in
interested in in moral questions that as
a philosopher at least at that time you
know if if Buddhists are good people
and they understand why it's important
to be honest and fair and why sharing is
good and why we defend each other and so
on then and they don't have these
absolute rules that say you must always
do X and y then then maybe there is
something deeply wrong with the way
moral theorists are looking at these
things but I didn't really pick up on it
in in a systematic way because at that
point I still didn't really understand
how neuroscience could ever really make
inroads into understanding something
like empathy or loyalty or honestly I
thought well how the heck I mean you
know we don't understand how stereo
optic vision works we're gonna get
empathy I mean give me a break so so I
just put it on the shelf but it raises
we should get out of the way a little
bit of a discussion of the odd verses is
problem right so just yeah we talked
about a little bit here I mean the word
neuro philosophy raises the danger that
you're gonna tell us you're gonna do an
fMRI and then I me what is right and
what is wrong
yeah no no that that really is not I
mean social life is so incredibly
complicated that that wouldn't be
possible but what is common amongst all
of us is something that we of course
also share with all mammals and and that
is the wiring that makes us sensitive to
others and it does so because we form
attachments to others in the first
analysis to our children our babies our
offspring and and that's a kind of
general platform that allows for the
ambit of care of myself where I see to
my own food and warmth and safety for
the ambit of my care to
expand so I see to the food and warmth
and safety of others in particular of
course to the offspring and as you know
anybody who observes the animals at all
know is how ferocious any mother is of
the newborns whether it's a mother rat
or a squirrel or a bear
a mother human they do the most heroic
things and we know a little bit now
about the circuitry for that so we do
see social behavior of course in insects
and wonderful Ed Wilson of course is
somebody who's thought very long deeply
about this but we know the social
behavior in mammals and in birds is
different right and I do when I get to
the mammals in particularly but yeah I'm
still I still want to make sure that we
understand that you're not aiming to
derive out from it yeah III think that
that the way to think about it is that
our biological constraints put
constraints on what rules makes sense to
us so that if you were to have a rule
that said all firstborn babies should be
boiled in water and eaten people could
not do that right the biology isn't the
biology constrains us and it's not just
the biology of caring and affection but
other aspects of problem solving and so
forth so there there is a kind of
limited way in which the science can say
about a certain proposed rule such as
the the obnoxious rule I suggested that
that that's not a rule that's gonna work
right however having said that I do
agree with you that what we as
scientists can't do is say you know we
see how the brain works utilitarianism
is the way to go yeah you laugh no no I
know who says that I do and I tried to
talk him out of that
at one point but but he was really very
convinced that science endorses
utilitarianism and it doesn't it doesn't
know um and and in in the new book I do
talk a lot about why science couldn't do
that but in particular you know what
scientists can do is help bring facts to
the table and and as human Adam Smith
were fond of pointing it we want all the
available facts but as a concerned
citizen the scientist might weigh in on
the dilemma whatever it happens to be
like shall we log old-growth forests
might bring the fact his his own or her
own opinion to the table but it's an it
doesn't count for more because it comes
from a scientist yes and scientists who
take the moral high ground in this way I
really I think hurting the case because
the fact of the matter is there are
wonderfully deeply wise uneducated
people who ever have who are very moral
who have the education of the world so
to speak yeah
whereas there are moral philosophers to
whom you would never go for advice if
you had a moral problem okay behaved
abominably and so so I think I think
it's not that that is a distinction is
so hard and fast that we don't want to
take into account these biological
constraints that are on us like we have
physical limitations we have certain
psychological limitations such as not
killing your firstborn or any of your
children and and and so that makes the
boundary a little bit fuzzy I think that
you know everybody already knows that
exactly I mean everyone knows that
learning things that are true about the
world will be relevant to what decisions
we making sure but there is some and you
know Hume understood this even though he
he sort of
ever quite articulated as cleanly as we
would like he was making fun of other
people rather than trying to make a
systematic point but there is just a
level of logic you need some input other
than descriptive facts about the world
you decide what is yes you do you do and
that can come from inside the scientist
and and his reward system and his
hypothalamus inside the scientist can
also come from inside the carpenter and
the fisherman yeah yeah and so I think
that will get will sort of circle back
at the end to you know ideas or
proposals for how we should think about
right and wrong and morality but let's
yeah let's sort of take I can't do
better than take the path you took in
the book which is sort of trying to talk
about our brains and how they evolved in
the particular way that they did and you
put a lot of emphasis on the transition
at which mammals first appeared yes yes
what's so great about mammals what's so
great about mouths indeed well the thing
is that we know that mammals and n birds
but we'll focus on them we know that
they all in every case the mother cares
about the offspring and we are pretty
sure that part of what happened was in
the evolution of the mammalian nervous
system the wiring for self care was
modified and repurposed because so our
listeners are all mammals so they might
not know that many other animal species
don't care yeah I mean a salamander lays
her eggs off she goes she doesn't care
what happens to them I mean it doesn't
occur to her to care and even if she saw
some bird pecking away at them
she might not do anything she'd just go
off and surf or whatever it is and and
so yeah it's it is very different now as
some of your listeners will know there
are some reptiles who sort of do care
alligators famously we don't know
whether that's an instance of convergent
evolution or not but the question that I
want to ask about this thing about
mammals is why did it happen right yeah
and you and you start talking about the
origin of being war
blooded as as a crucial point it seems
that that was the crucial thing was that
at some point in in our evolutionary
past these warm blooded creatures who
weren't yet fully mammals they were kind
of warm blooded reptiles appeared so
we're talking 250 million about 2
million years ago and the great thing
about being warm-blooded was that you
could do this really cool thing you
could feed at night and nobody else was
there
yum yum but they is open and all these
guys these insects were lying around
waiting for the Sun to come up and you
could yes buffet so it was a great great
thing however it's been observed that
gram for gram you have to eat 10 times
as much if you're warm-blooded as your
cold-blooded cousins so that's a huge
constraint so the hypothesis is that
over time mother nature so to speak
realize that in order to solve this
problem of calories one thing to do is
to be smart now there's a couple of ways
you can go to be smart one is to build
it all in with the genes so that for
every contingency that arises you know
what to do the problem with that of
course is that when the world changes
you're kind of stuck the other problem
is that it takes place over very long
timescales whereas if what you do if
you're mother nature is you say let's
crank out learning let's take those
learning mechanisms and just crank that
crap out of them and then let's see if
we get smart and that was basically the
strategy and thus we see in mammals and
only in mammals this remarkable
structure that makes us smart and that's
the cortex right now it's not that frogs
are super dumb I mean they're not like
rocks but but and they do learn but they
what they can learn is highly
constrained and very
minimal whereas even a modest rat can
learn a lot a lot about its spatial
organization a lot about what to avoid
how to get on and so forth so so the
great thing was then that you're
warm-blooded and you're gonna be smart
but wait there is a problem if you're
going to be smart
then the neurons that you have when
you're born have to be able to grow
because the only way that learning
happens in nervous systems is that
structure gets built so you've got to
have the genes to make structure and the
structure has to go to the right places
but if you gotta have lots of room in
order to grow your brain then you have
to be born very immature just because
you can't fit the big brain
well not just that there are sort of
deep developmental reasons too that have
to do with how far learning can go in a
circuit and so if you want to maximize
for learning you better be like
conscious and out there in the world for
a boss that's right that's nice yeah you
gotta be out there and yet and your
nervous system has to be immature so it
can do all these things which and other
things are done in the egg so so then
the problem that somehow evolution
solved was to say well basically look
the only thing is we've got to have
somebody take care of these these highly
dependent going to be smart creatures
the mums the only one around so you know
let's tap her so so essentially then
what happened was that the circuitry of
the ancient structures the hypothalamus
and the brainstem were changed
integrated into cortex and you had
mothers who now felt pain when their
infants were away from them felt good
felt pleasure when they were close by
pain when they cried
when they were warm and sand and so
forth and this is a very typical
strategy in the history revolution where
you have something in your body that
does something and rather than come up
with an entirely new system to do
something new
you adapt the existing system so here we
had organisms which already had
self-preservation instincts yeah and we
just sort of evolutions that extend that
a little bit to your brood yes and and
the pleasure in pain for self survival
was kind of repurposed and modified as
well right and so you get this system of
social pain and social pleasure at the
theme but it really that appears to have
come from this more fundamental more
fundamental system of self care but bear
in mind too that self care doesn't go
away once yep so so and then it
naturally extends out to people beyond
our office well depending on what
happens so I presume that in the history
of the evolution of the mammalian brain
probably in the early days only the
mothers did the work in the way that
it's only the mother for bears but you
know even in mice the dad often helps
and in other species of rodents the
father helped you'd like to think that
in human beings the father helps
sometimes oh for sure for absolutely for
sure and so what we know is that much
depends on the species but the thing
seems to be that once you've got this
circuitry for care that sort of platform
for care in place you can tweak it a bit
and you can tweak it so that now you're
caring for mates and now we see things
like the prairie voles or beavers where
they mate for life they care about each
other they are by parental they both
take care of the babies and humans which
are different yet again we're not quite
like beavers not quite like chimpanzees
so you know each species has its unique
way of being
social but pretty clearly in humans
there are big strong attachments within
the family to mates to can even to
cousins to Fran's and sometimes well
beyond that we have to talk about the
prairie voles because those crucial in
saying not only that there's some
mechanism that makes us attached to
other people our relatives and our
friends and so forth but actually
helping to identify part of what that
mechanism is that was the thing that
made me realize that there was going to
be a biological story about morality
that I hadn't foreseen so the story of
the prairie voles and the Montaigne
rules or lots of rules goes like this so
the many species of Falls
phenomenologically they're very similar
they look the same they're kind of
weighed the same they have about the
same number of babies and so forth but
socially they're very different
so prairie voles mate for life after the
first sexual encounter they stayed
together for life and the male guard the
nest they provision the female they
huddle over the babies montane voles are
completely different they are what we
sort of customarily think of as a rodent
and that is that the male and the female
meet they mate and then they go their
separate ways so when the this
difference in social behavior was
discovered some neuroscientist said
what's the difference in the brain here
we've got these two species that are so
similar what's the difference in the
brain and after a lot of false starts
and looking and wondering they
discovered that the the neurochemical
oxytocin has a high density of receptors
in a very special part of the reward
system in the prairie voles doesn't have
it in the montains voles and there is a
sibling molecule called vasopressin
sibling to oxytocin is just differs in a
couple of amino acids
and it turns out that vasopressin is
also special in the Prairie vole because
here again there's a high density of
receptors for this vasopressin in a very
special part of the reward system not so
in the Montaigne voles so with that
correlation inhale then the researchers
really went to work is it causal and you
do all the manipulations and they showed
it is causal now it's probably not the
whole story
of course and we know that there are
other things that matter but it is a
significant part of the story so that
the bonding between mates is critical
critically dependent on oxytocin
receptors and I am all on board with the
idea that this is a big part but it's
very complicated and you should
emphasize the complications but I still
like the idea that oxytocin is the
cuddle molecule well it just blew my
socks off when when Larry Jung came here
to the Salk to give this talk it had a
very boring title and I sort of went
because I think and I just sat there my
jaw dropped that something as simple as
receptor density I mean could could be
the hub of something that we thought of
was socially extremely subtle and
complex monogamy I mean really yes and
they turn on and off the levels of
oxytocin or the the efficiency of the
receptors and the monogamy comes and
goes comes and goes and that's just
something that human beings are gonna
find scary right like even if you would
ask someone is our behavior ultimately
expression of what goes on in our brain
and they said yes and but then you point
like here's the molecule doing it or the
system molecules doing it there that you
know scares us a little bit that seems
like it someone could turn off the
receptors for authy Tosun in my brain
and i would not be loved with my wife
anymore
yeah it's okay yeah yeah it is kind of
terrible but on the other hand you know
somebody can put a hole in my head in a
certain place and I won't be able to
talk anymore or you'd be dead all right
definitely effect but it is it is a
remarkable discovery yeah and but as you
say of course it's complex but the other
part of the story that I really love is
that oxytocin works hand-in-hand with
the endogenous opioids and the
endogenous cannabinoids that our brain
makes so part of the pleasure you feel
when you pick up that crying baby and
you hold it and it stops crying and you
feel that wonderful softness and so
forth a lot of that is endocannabinoids
okay which isn't to say you're high it's
just to say that the pleasure of that is
dependent on certain neural chemicals
and the endocannabinoids play a big role
and just to be very clear for the non
experts among whom I include myself
these are what we're talking about our
peptides chemicals neurotransmitters
that get received by individual neurons
right so basically the existence of
these chemicals and the right parts of
the brain will make us more empathetic
or yeah roughly the story I mean the
thing is that that the way neurons work
is that they they have have a little
receptor on them and it's only when the
molecule fits into that receptor that
the neuron has a response to the
molecule and so receptor density is
really important because if you have a
ton of oxytocin flashing around in your
brain but you got no receptors it isn't
gonna help right so you have to have the
receptors there and that's why one of
the things that I think was so important
that came out of this work was our
understanding that that these two gotta
fit together and how does it work you
know could when my cat jumps on my lap
and starts purring I'm sure that
oxytocin oh my green so how does the
brain know what is the signal where does
the oxytocin come from the oxytocin
comes from the hypothalamus
and it's it's released in the
hypothalamus but it's also in cortex now
it took a while for us to sort of know
that because the first things that were
looked at of course were voles and and
there isn't so much in bowls in cortex
but in monkeys there's quite a lot and
so it's released from these sites when
when we have these warm social
interactions now part of the reason for
this
I mean Mother Nature doesn't really care
if we feel good or not
right I mean evolution don't have to be
so so so so what's the what's the thing
and and the answer really is that that
when the stress hormones go up oxytocin
goes down but when oxytocin goes down up
when oxytocin goes out the stress
hormones go down and so oxytocin makes
us feel good and so then we can do
certain things and if you're mother
nature and you want your a mother this
mom to take care of these babies you
want her to feel good about this so you
raise her levels of oxytocin when she's
caring for the babies and things are
going well you raise her stress hormones
when the cats are around sniffing out
the babies and and that provokes or you
know initiates different behavior
patterns so oxytocin you know we we
think of oxytocin as being the love
molecule so yeah but you know the fact
is that it's truly truly ancient well
before mammals and it's just that it was
repurposed evolution being what it is it
was repurposed in mammals so that there
is this relationship between stress and
oxytocin levels stress goes down when
oxytocin goes up and that's super
important when you think about the
sociality of mammals and and how
important I mean Mike Gazzaniga what's
said to be you know don't you find it
odd that there's as live
murder amongst humans as their but yeah
but what he was pointing out was that
that often people are really really
annoying and irritating and they say
stupid things and they do stupid things
what's remarkable is how we just you
know we just let it roll off don't
murder them we mostly don't and so so
where was I going with oh yeah so so
oxytocin is is really very important for
all kinds of social functioning and of
course as you know there are social
species where there isn't monogamous
pair bonding as there is involves and TT
monkeys and to a first approximation
humans is the oxytocin was it some
arbitrary choice for what the molecule
would be is basically just signaling the
fact of empathy or compassion or is
there something actually about that
molecular structure that is useful to
that particular neuro chemical use it's
a really interesting question and I've
thought about it and I think the neuro
chemists would probably be able to say
more about it then then I could it does
lower levels of stress and and so when
stress levels are lower and this you
know could be in a lizard when stress
levels are lowered that allows certain
other things to happen and so part of
sociality isn't just that we're drawn to
each other but that when I'm not
threatened and the stress levels go down
then I'm comfortable and then and then
maybe we can cooperate on something you
know we and and so highly social animals
find it of course very useful to have
have fairly high levels of oxytocin so
they can accomplish things jointly this
discussion is amazing it fires up a
couple of issues I'm just going to throw
them out there there are tangents but
then we'll come back one tangent is does
this kind of discussion raise obstacles
for
people who would want us to upload our
consciousnesses into computers where
there's the equivalent of neurons but
maybe not the equivalent of these
hormones that are changing the receptors
yeah I mean I don't see how you could do
it at this stage I don't and and it
isn't it isn't just oxytocin of course
there's also vasopressin and and and and
the the endogenous cannabinoids and the
endogenous opioids which play really I
mean we think of them as you know well
we know them via street drugs right but
but they play a hugely critical role and
and bonding between parents and
offspring and in bonding across
community and in people managing to get
on with each other even though you know
the other guys are a bit nasty or smell
bad or get bad things and so forth so so
the biochemistry the whole story is of
course very very complex but but in a
certain really important way oxytocin
and vasopressin are at the heart of it
but I do want to stress the importance
of the opioids and cannabinoids and but
always not always but I've had wanders
worries about the matrix about the idea
that we could you know have our
existence inside to simulate an eye on
things I mean in principle I'm sure it's
possible but I think that people who
think about it under value the
importance of the fact that we're in a
body our brains right are you tired we
get thirsty we get irritated and you're
sort of bringing something else we have
all these you know hormones being turned
on and turned off to change how our
brains work absolutely even if you can't
do it in principle it's really not gonna
be it's gonna be even more complicated
than finding out what every neuron does
I think it is I think it's going to be
super complicated because you know if
you just if you imagine that neurons
communicate with just one
neurotransmitter and that's all there is
to it well you know sadly it ain't like
that and it's the the neuro chemistry is
really really complex and there are many
fundamental issues which are still not
resolved
good and then the other tangent that I
wanted to I need to ask this almost
every single podcast all of these facts
about the relationship of canvas
chemicals in our brain and how we behave
and think brings up questions about free
will yeah yeah yeah for sure
so is there nevertheless space for
talking about people as autonomous
decision-making agents or are we just
bundles of chemical networks well it
depends on how how you really want to
think about freewill and certainly there
is space for contemplated choice or what
you might even want to call rational
choice almost certainly the the brain is
a causal machine and we certainly do
feel differently and make different
kinds of decisions as a function of the
neuro chemicals that have to be sloshing
around and is that a particular diet ID
when you're really tired you're not the
same as when you you have have just
woken up on the other hand the whole
issue of freewill really arises in a
very special context it arises in the
context of the law and of holding people
responsible blaming responsible and
their the question is whether or not we
want to hold somebody anybody
responsible for antisocial things that
they do like just you know for the sheer
fun of it murdering all kinds of folks
and and on that question it seems that
that we proceed really by looking at
sort of stereotypical examples of people
who really are out of their minds and
people who do really terrible things but
are not out of their minds and so
somebody like Bernie Madoff who over the
course of 20 years ran a Ponzi scheme
that was extremely elaborate I happen to
have met him what section of yeah and
didn't invest I hope no no no I crazily
enough it was at an MIT event and I was
seated next to him at a table and I I
tried to make conversation
with him and and he wasn't having it and
before he was a notorious criminal yes
before he was a notorious crime it
happened I think about six months later
so he was probably because he was yad
more on his mind that making
conversation with a Californian but but
in the case of someone like like Madoff
where it was clearly a forethought and
well worked out so of course you've got
to hold them or some kind of passion it
was not a crime of passion so so the
distinctions that the law already makes
are actually in many ways very sensible
other things we can do to improve the
law part of which would be applying the
law as it actually is but the fact that
we are a causal machines is not really
relevant in the case of I mean it's no
excuse for Bernie Madoff to say but I'm
a causal machine right so good so I
think I'm completely on board with that
and I'll consider it our tangents to be
closed we can come back to the story of
mammalian evolution and we've evolved
this capability of feeling empathy
toward other people and are we going to
say this is the precursor of our moral
instincts and intuitions yeah I think
something like that is I mean all all
highly social animals have some sorts of
rules of odes how they get on and what
they can do and when they have to stop
fighting and when it's okay to have a
short fight and so forth some of those
rules may actually be part of their
innate endowment some of them may have
been socially constructed as time went
on and I really think of morality
as a kind of socially enforced
set of constructs that that come into
being and they're different for
different communities living in very
different conditions I mean what the
moral system that worked very well for
the Inuit in the nineteenth century for
example is very different from what
might have worked very well in Paris at
the same time so these were people
living in small groups they knew that
they were living in tremendously harsh
conditions and that you couldn't have
certain kinds of crime like murders and
when people didn't get along especially
when men didn't get along because they
were fighting over women they had these
very elaborate rituals where they had a
kind of salt what they call the song
jewel it kind of translates into that
okay and so so the they would have a day
or so to make up their songs and then
everybody would congregate in the igloo
and one guy would sing his song which
was usually nasty about the other guy
this track and and and then it was to be
resolved there was to be no more no more
fighting because you know if you're
living on the knife edge of survival and
your hunters kill each other as bad yeah
okay so so particular moral styles I
think grew out of this sort of basic
hardpan kind of of caring and and
wanting to be with others that is
provided by oxytocin and this lets us
loop back to the philosophy of morality
discussion so you have a very nice
chapter in your book about the rule
givers and the utilitarian so explain
explain the the these different
traditions in Western philosophy were
Lisa V morality yeah it's it is a very
interesting tradition and and I have to
confess that I wasn't very interested in
moral philosophy either as a graduate
student but certainly not as an
undergrad
it sounded to me like going to church to
be good but I got interested in moral
philosophy really as a result of the
prairie voles and and realizing that
these really quite strong behavioral
patterns could emerge as a result of
rather simple chemical changes in having
the appropriate neurons in the
appropriate place so there are are
within the philosophical tradition there
are the the people who think of rules as
kind of the be-all and the end-all and
the people who think that you can have
rules of thumb and that's really kind of
about it but that if people grow up in
the right kind of atmosphere with the
right kind of community they will have
the right dispositions and they won't
need to rely on these highly specific
rules so can't of course belongs in the
rule group so if I understand correctly
and people will listen to previous
episodes of the podcast there's a
well-known station between de ontology
and consequentialists right people who
think that right or wrong and here's and
what you do versus people who think that
right or wrong in here is in the
consequences of what you do you're
lumping both of those people into the
rule yes right cam thank you mother
yes so so most if I can just dis
philosophy departments for a while what
was the philosophy departments have
ethicists who say there's really two
traditions in philosophy there's that
there's the utilitarians and then there
is the day oncologists the gang says
yeah yeah and they're neglecting a whole
rich interesting tradition that includes
Aristotle of course Hume David Smith
Confucius and a few other fairly smart
folks so when I thought about how it
could be the oxytocin and the related
neuro chemicals in the brain affect
social behavior
it seemed to me that that the rule guys
the day on tala just sand the
utilitarians didn't really have much to
offer so so that was kind of the basic
way that I wanted to look at it but some
very real sense they're both part of
this tradition of finding using pure
reason they're losing pure reason
and of course everybody knows that when
a moral decision is made that there are
lots of emotions involved too now we
also know that you don't want the
emotions to run away with you and so
forth but that the emotions do of course
play an extremely important role and you
have in the book substantive you know
objections to both the idea that you can
be a day intelligent like a contour you
could be you told like me yeah yeah yeah
and and you know the mill now funnily
enough it doesn't come across it quite
the bad guy because I think he realized
especially later in life that
utilitarianism had had tremendous
limitations but that it kind of worked
to a first approximation if you don't
look too closely right and on the other
hand I think that the 19th century
philosophers and many thereafter liked
the idea not of just relying on people's
good judgment and internal sense
propriety
they want rules well so I'm sympathetic
to this I think that I'm evolving
personally I think that I was a
utilitarian growing up and now I'm
moving into this sort of non rule-based
camp but part of me thinks you know
there's there's an argument that says if
I knew in every specific instance in
every conceivable circumstance what the
right thing to do was or not even know
if I had an opinion about that I can
always reverse engineer a rule that
recovers all of those instances right it
might be a very very complicated rule is
the problem with rules that
they're that simple rules are just too
simple or there are more metaphysical
objection it's a really really good
question no the problem is that we're
not smart enough yeah
and that we are smart enough to
recognize an exception to the rule and
to realize that everything would be a
lot better if you just tweaked it a bit
here and tweaked it a bit there and then
and we all know of morally really really
decent people who don't always adhere to
the rules they they are sometimes
especially merciful on occasion or they
are sometimes especially kind on an
occasion and so forth and so so it
seemed to me that that when when you
sort when people kind of really look at
what's on offer from utilitarians and
from deontologists like the contents it
doesn't really it doesn't really match
into the real social world in a very
comfortable way on the other hand we do
like things to be cut and dried we we
look at confucius for example or hume or
smith who are not giving us precise
rules and and we think well then you
know how do you ever get it right how do
i how can I be sure yeah there should be
an answer yes very human it's a very
human quality we want to know and we
also everybody knows that if you do what
Martin Luther King's I know I'm sorry
Martin Luther said which was rely on
your conscience because God will always
give you the right answer
well you know that's wrong yeah that
sometimes our conscience isn't up to it
we can't we certain things we didn't
foresee or we were too young or we were
too tired or we were too scared I've
always thought there's a parallel
between moral philosophy and bureaucracy
in the sense that you start from some
good goals and then make up a list of
rules and then you forget what the goals
were and you stick with the rule that's
right and the rules become important
bureaucracies are terrible because
following the rule that is an
interesting analogy so so I understand
that it's hard to think about being
moral in the way that sake Confucius
would recommend or that Aristotle would
recommend but it can't be that hard
because the confusions do it right and
they're not noticeably more immoral than
are say Christians or Jews or people who
had here two very specific rules and so
you're certainly not deriving on from is
but it does sound like you're being
inspired by the biological realities to
sort of take them into account when we
try to think about when we construct our
view of how to be moral I think we do I
mean I think how we get to the point of
making moral decisions is really poorly
understood it's it's in some sense a
constraint satisfaction process but we
don't really I mean that's not saying
anything very substantive we really
don't know how that works
right and I it's not that I think we
won't ever but I don't think we're even
close at this point and that's why it
was sometimes I you know I I grew up on
a farm and yeah that farmers where I
grew up
nobody had any education I mean the but
these were smart good and interesting
people and I often go back and I think
about the conversations they would have
at night be this you know kids supposed
to be in bed listening away to them and
and there was just a lot of good common
sense yeah and then I contrast that with
some of the philosophical discussions I
hear in philosophy departments and I
think this it doesn't it doesn't compute
for me well let me bring up the obvious
worry about this that people have I
don't necessarily have it myself but
it's just moral relativism you're saying
that whoever
to make up whatever rules they can make
up like if you don't give me an absent
guideline doesn't everything descend
into chaos it is a really interesting
question and somehow I think theologians
have sort of taught us to believe that I
said exactly those words because you
know I mean our Confucians and Buddhists
in that problem I don't think so they
seem to do very well and there I have a
friend who's a child psychologist
experimental psychologist in Canada and
in Vancouver it's a nice place to
compare how Asian children and how kids
who have our fourth generation Canadian
how they differ first generation Asian
and 4th generation Canadian and and they
differ in in really quite interesting
ways the Canadian kids when presented
with a moral dilemma say well the rule
is this and the Asian kids say well it
could be this but is do we know about X
do we know about Y because if we do if
it's Z then we have to do something else
so so they do come from a tradition of
thinking about it in a different way now
that doesn't mean I'm not you know
saying that that the the Christian kids
are totally messed up or anything of
that kind because I think in their
actual life they behave much the verge
to find the rule the urge to articulate
and say that's what you're doing but
mostly that's not what you're doing
right which i think is really
terrifically interesting well and that
comes back to yo you the title of your
book is conscience I keep wanting to say
conscious because of course you've also
done yeah important work on
consciousness but conscience you know it
it conjures up to me the fact that we
human beings are not these unified cells
right we have lots of different voices
talking in our heads and we you know and
for morph eyes the conscious conscience
as Jiminy Cricket right like a separate
voice talking to us
and so and neurobiologically this makes
all the sense in the world
how do you see that role of the
conscience inside ourselves as feeding
into the moral conversation in our
brains well you know I'm not sure and
part of the reason I'm not sure is is
sort of historical and that is the
Greeks never had a word for it the
Greeks to whom we look for such wisdom
in all of these matters Socrates did
have a demon Socrates had a demon but it
wasn't quite the same so where did the
word conscience come from well actually
it was invented by the Romans and it was
to mean knowledge of what is expected of
you in terms of the law but then of
course we have come it means something
quite different to us now but there were
the Greeks for hundreds of years
merrily talking about the nature of
ethics and values and how to think about
it and whether there are otherworldly or
this worldly and they didn't have a word
for it
so I say to myself how important is this
word yeah and then I look at how people
actually use the word and it's been
observed by many linguists that it
mostly only comes up in the context
where something goes wrong and shouldn't
your company's doing yeah yeah because
and as you mentioned very early you know
sometimes our conscience is not right
right like it's another part of our
system that comes from evolution and
training and so forth and it serves an
important purpose but it's by no means
the final law ya know and it's it's
certainly not infallible a heaven knows
and you know you look back on your own
sort of life especially as an adolescent
where you know you would claim you were
doing this for reasons of conscience and
you think oh god help me you know why
didn't somebody just sort of you know
set me straight on this
so so yeah I don't know how important
the word is but I chose to use it for a
book because it does resonate with what
we are really interested in and that is
our moral understanding and what it
rests on that is that the instincts and
the innate sort of circuitry that it
rests on and how it can grow and develop
as you are a person in the world so is
there a is there a word for this school
of thought that is more confusion or
Buddhist or Aristotelian that is not
rule-based I've heard virtue ethics yeah
as a term is that it sort of is and I
tended not to use it and the reason I
tended not to is that the virtue ethics
people those who are philosophers that
is to say are not really interested in
the brain at all right they want to do
it all without talking about the brain
and yeah it seems like it's the I guess
this is this is a good place to start
wrapping up so I was going to say as a
sort of the final question you know how
do you see the future progressing in
terms of the conversation between
morality conceived of as a bunch of good
ideas that we have that don't
necessarily simplify under rules and our
improving understanding of the brain and
all of its little subsystems working
together I don't know I think it's
really hard to see I think I to think
that that only that sort of dumb and
religious people took courses in moral
philosophy when I was an undergrad or
that I know that's very bad of me but I
did I now think about rather differently
I think it's a really really difficult
subject because it you know if you're
thinking about a single brain and how a
single brain manages to organize itself
so the body it's in can walk that's an
that's a tough problem already hard but
it's already hard but when you're
talking
about how groups of individuals managed
to get on right then I think it's really
really difficult on the other hand you
know I never would have predicted the
oxytocin story it absolutely blew me
away
Francis Crick and I used to talk about
morality a lot because he really
wondered what the basis for it was he
said it can't just be that it's taught
he thought was just you know up a tree
and it has he was much more of the human
persuasion as I was so that was kind of
a born between us I guess you think I
have to find some con Dean's to get on
the podcast because I'm definitely
slanted towards the humans by a big
margin myself well you're in the
minority I mean if you go to the
philosophy meetings the contents are
coming out of the woodwork they are yeah
and it is really horrendously
complicated how we how we managed to
interact but on the other hand what's
kind of amazing and this kind of takes
me back to Mike Gazzaniga is how well
actually we do get along I mean of
course it's true that there are terrible
wars and and and there is class warfare
within the nation and so forth
nevertheless as Mike would put it given
how annoying other people are it's
surprising how few choice and how fairly
easy it is to kill people to kill people
and it also gives me a little bit of
hope this is a much narrower narrower
scope but this kind of perspective is a
different way of thinking about the
relationship between science and the
humanities I think it is there's a way
of saying that the relationship is that
the communities should be subsumed into
Sciences and this is not that this is a
truth I think it is and and I I used to
Paul anion and our kids used to sit in
the hot tub and at home and have these
long arguments about morality and
whether there was any point in studying
it or understanding it this was long ago
of course and and I would just despair I
mean I think you know if we're
not going to understand anything about
really how the brain is interested in
these things and where these social
urges come from we're not going to make
any progress but now I kind of feel I
feel very differently about it I mean I
think this this is a very deep feature
of all mammals all mammals I mean the
highly social ones are very striking
because they live in groups but there's
there's actually some evidence that
those mammals who are loners are
actually have a suppression of their
sociality in order that they can
function alone because they need to for
their own ecological reasons but now it
does seem to me that that there are
really deep things that we can
understand about the nature of sociality
and and how how to get better and so
forth I mean is it fair to say that if
you're willing at the philosophical
level to say that morality is something
that we construct and and you know base
and sort of informal ways on our
intuitions rather than pure reason then
knowing more about how the brain works
and now the chemicals inside of work
provide a useful starting point for
finding out what our commonalities are I
really think so yeah I really do think
so yeah and and and I think I think that
that would actually be an amazing and
quite wonderful sort of thing I mean
there are many huge questions that
remain any sense to person of course
realizes how dreadful it is to
incarcerate people who break the law and
of course when I used to teach
philosophy there were always
undergraduates who would say you know
there's got to be a better way and
sometimes some at some point in our
development there will be a better way
in the meanwhile of course it's hard to
know what else to do I mean psychopaths
are pretty scary folks right and but I
like it I think we've given us given
ourselves a little optimistic place to
end and see how things are moving
forward it's nice to see that there's
also a little bit of progress even in
philosophy as far as I
yeah well except III don't know I mean I
think that well as a sort of rough index
of whether philosophers take what I have
to say seriously I am never invited to
give a talk in a philosophy department
or almost never whereas I've been all
over the world of course to talk to
neuroscience departments and and I think
I think that's because they really don't
want to hear this message now I think
the next generation will I think things
are changing
yeah and so I'm hopeful but but it it I
think I was just very naive
I thought philosophers would think oh
wow this is really cool and they did not
well let's choose to be hopeful about
the next generation all right Patricia
Churchland thanks so much for being
[Music]